BRIAN KEHRER: Hello, everyone.
Thank you for coming.
I'm Brian.
I'm a game developer
and graphics programmer.
I was cofounder of
Muse Games where
I was lead game designer on a
game you might have heard of,
"Guns of Icarus Online."
After that, I spent
a couple years
working on mobile games and
experiences at Psyop New York.
But today I'm
going to talk about
some work I did last year with
ustwo in New York on two VR
projects, which I'm
sure you've heard of,
Cardboard Design Lab
and "Arctic Journey."
So what I really
wanted to talk about
is how vertex displacement, a
feature in the Cardboard SDK,
was developed for the needs
of both those projects,
and how it can help you develop
performant VR experiences.
So the first project is
Cardboard Design Lab.
It was released early last year.
Hopefully you've
all tried it out.
If you haven't, I highly
recommend getting it.
It's also open source.
So you can, in addition
to testing it out,
you can mess around
with it, get it
to build on other platforms,
anything you want.
But the primary
purpose of Design Lab
is to showcase best practices
in VR for Cardboard developers,
as well as some
activities best avoided.
But beyond just
the principles, it
was important that the
experience also be beautiful,
and of course run smoothly
at 60 frames per second.
We wanted Design Lab to
embody what a Cardboard
experience could and should be.
But at the same time,
we really wanted
to push the limits of what's
possible on a mobile device.
We wanted to create lush visuals
and have high performance
at the same time.
So we set an ambitious
goal for ourself.
Let's see if we can achieve
this look while still hitting
60 frames per
second on a Nexus 5,
and maybe throw in antialiasing
and some dynamic lights.
But we ran into problems.
Almost immediately
we realized this was
going to be really challenging.
Older devices were struggling
to hit 30 frames per second
on even simple test scenes.
They were overheating.
So during the development
of Design Lab,
we experimented with a new
method of distortion correction
called vertex displacement.
And I'll get to
that in a minute.
But I just want to sort of
put this in context first.
Without vertex
displacement, most
of what you see in Design Lab
would not have been possible.
But then we didn't stop there.
So fast forward
six months and we
worked on the second
project, and that's
"Arctic Journey," which
is the demo project
or the demo scene in
the Cardboard app.
And this time we wanted
to push it even further,
adding more animated characters,
richer lighting, and a more
dynamic environment.
And this project gave us
one of those rare chances
to reflect on the
lessons we'd learned
before while working on Design
Lab and refine our workflow.
So we set an even
more ambitious goal.
Let's see if we can
do the same thing,
but this time make it richer
and run on older devices.
We knew antialiasing on old
phones was almost impossible.
But maybe we could get
them to at least run at 60.
So in this case,
we were targeting
the S3, the iPhone 5, the S4.
And if you've worked with
any of these devices,
they're really challenging,
especially for Cardboard apps.
So I've sort of broken
this talk into two parts
to mirror the evolution of
our workflow and these two
projects.
And first I'm going
to talk about what
is vertex displacement.
How do you use it?
How can it help you?
And second I'm going to step
back and go a bit more broad.
How can you take advantage
of some of these lessons
to further optimize
performance in other ways?
So first, let's talk
about vertex displacement.
But to do that, we need
to really quickly talk
about how VR rendering works.
So here's a Cardboard
application.
On your device, you render
the left and right eye
on your smartphone.
And then you pick
up your Cardboard,
and you look at them
through the lenses.
And these lenses are what
create the wide field of view.
But because as with
any lenses they
warp the image, if you render
out this Cardboard icon the way
you see it and look
through the Cardboard,
you'll see an image
that's distorted.
So instead, we render with
the inverse of that lens
distortion applied.
And this happens
in our application
through the Cardboard SDK,
typically a postprocess image
effect or by
rendering to a texture
and projecting that
texture onto a warped mesh,
and then rerendering the screen.
So now when we look
through the lenses,
the distortion cancels out
and we see the correct image.
It's a fairly simple process.
But as graphics programmers
in the room know,
full screen render textures
are not free, especially
on older devices, devices
with dense screens, low power
devices.
These full screen
render textures
can create serious
performance problems.
So what we wanted to do was cut
this out and render directly
to the screen buffer instead.
But we needed a way to
apply the lens distortion
before rendering.
So what if instead of
warping the rendered image,
we just warped the
geometry before we
finished rendering, maybe in
a vertex shader, like that?
And this is what it
actually looks like.
So this is the optical
distortion correction
being applied in
the vertex shader,
animated here for effect.
So instead of transforming
individual pixels
from the rendered image,
we bent the actual world
and then just rendered normally.
So we no longer need
a render texture.
I think this is pretty awesome.
You can see in this
wireframe image,
as vertices extend outward
from the center of the screen,
they're affected more, just
like a Photoshop lens correction
effect.
This is extremely
efficient, especially
on older, lower power devices.
This can represent a large
increase in performance.
On the S3, this
doubles performance.
On newer devices, you'll
see less of an impact.
I think on the
5S, the iPhone, it
was 20% to 30% increase
in performance.
OK, so this is great.
But there are some drawbacks.
Mostly because this method
only operates on vertices,
you can see lines
between vertices
always remain straight.
So the quality of this effect is
dependent on both the distance
from the camera as well as the
vertex density of the scene.
So you might wonder, how
many vertices do we need?
And I've put two foxes here.
And one of these
images is rendered
using the new technique,
vertex displacement.
And the other is rendered
using a render texture
at double resolution.
Both are just using simple
Lambertian diffuse, N dot L.
And they're almost identical.
So you might say like OK,
well how dense is this mesh?
And the answer is
it's not that dense.
So we don't need too much.
And here's-- I don't
know if you can see this.
It's a little tough to
see, this is an error image
between the postprocess and
the vertex displacement.
And it looks pretty good.
So you might wonder
OK, this is great.
How low can we go?
Like what about a quad?
And so a quad is the perfect
example of this not working.
No matter how you
warp it, the edges
are always going to be
lines when they should
be a curved arc between points.
So you're going to need
some additional tessellation
on really low poly geometry.
But again, the good news
is you don't need a lot.
The four by four quad is
already looking passable,
and the eight by eight
looks pretty good.
And in fact, when we once
again compare the eight
by eight quad to the render
texture at double res,
the resulting difference
image isn't that far off.
And I'll note, if you're
looking at a piece of geometry,
that's a very large
piece of geometry
very close to your eye.
So this represents
kind of a worst case
scenario for this technique.
And as you can see again,
it's doing quite well
with very low tessellation.
You could very easily
increase the tessellation
of this geometry without really
affecting your vertex budget.
So in summary, if you decide
to use this, be forewarned,
you're going to have
to be a little bit
careful about tessellation.
But you don't need
to go crazy either.
So one of the places this
is potentially problematic
and a little bit irritating
is on interface elements.
And on both these
projects, we generally
swapped out all the quads
for 10 by 10 planes,
and then we just didn't
think about it again.
This covered it.
Fortunately text, each
character is rendered on a quad.
And those were small enough that
it wasn't really noticeable.
If you're building
interfaces in 3D space
with physics, as we
did in Design Lab,
using custom geometry for
your back plates in your UI
is really easy.
If you're using the existing
UI systems in Unity,
it's still possible, but it's
a little bit more involved.
OK, so so far I've
described how this works.
I've talked a little bit about
performance and tessellation.
But I want to talk about
one of the other side
benefits of vertex
displacement, and that's
a dramatic gain in resolving
power on the screen.
So this image is comparing
vertex displacement
all the way on the left
to a render texture, again
set through Cardboard--
I think it's
called screen scale-- at
one time screen resolution
all the way up to two
time screen resolution,
all using 4x antialiasing.
And to my eye, the
vertex displacement
looks about as sharp
as rendering the screen
at 1 and 1/2 times
resolution, which
is a huge gain in performance.
Any time we can get an
extra 50% screen resolution
for free, that's great.
So you may be wondering,
OK, how does this work?
Why is this the case?
And this is maybe a
little hard to grok,
but I'll try and
take you through it.
If you remember from
before, because we're
distorting the
underlying geometry,
all of the interpreted
pixels actually get rendered.
Whereas if we do this
with a render texture,
we have to bilinearly
interpolate
between screen pixels.
So in this example, I
wrote a quick shader which
I've included most of
at the bottom here,
that just outputs eight
pixel lines based on screen
coordinates.
So this is a decent
proxy for resolution.
Thinner lines in
this image represent
areas of high resolution, thick
lines represent low resolution.
So in the vertex
displacement case,
everything's even, because
we're just rendering straight
to the screen buffer.
It looks like an even grid.
In the render texture, you
see in the center pixels
are getting blown up.
So then if we increase
the resolution to 1.5,
OK, we've matched
vertex displacement.
But now we're rendering
all these extra pixels
on the outer edge.
And that's all completely wasted
and you're not looking there.
So originally when we
used vertex displacement
it was because of the
great performance gains.
But the resolution enhancement
was really a great side effect.
And I bring it up now
because on newer devices
you might not be watching
performance as much, but maybe
for your Cardboard
application you really need
an extra kick in resolution.
OK, so I've talked enough.
It's great.
You want to just get started.
So I have good news.
This feature is fully supported
in the latest Cardboard
SDK for Unity, and it's
really easy to set up.
So on your Cardboard
prefab in the scene,
if you select
distortion correction,
just set it to none.
Turn it off.
Then you modify your shaders.
And that's it, you're done.
And so many of you,
modifying shaders,
that sounds really scary.
So let's just do that
together very quickly.
If you're writing your
own vertex and fragment
shaders, which if you
are, that's awesome.
I hope you are.
It's a one line include
and a one line change.
Instead of outputting the
vertex position multiplied
by the model view
projection matrix,
we include Cardboard
distortion and output
this undistort vertex function.
I've left the highlighting
in, but I've commented out
the old MVP matrix.
If you're doing advanced
things like shadows or anything
with depth, don't forget to
also write a modified depth
shader for any replace
shaders you're doing,
otherwise effects won't work.
And I'll come back to that
later and show you an example.
If on the other
hand you're using
Unity's built in
surface shaders,
you just need to add a
very simple vertex function
and add this one line.
So really this is
a simple thing.
Just create a new surface
shader, drop this in,
and you're good to go.
So let's talk about,
really quickly, how we did.
On Design Lab, we rendered
about 700,000 vertices,
or less, and under
100 draw calls.
And we generally made our goal
of saying near 60 on the Nexus
5.
That vertex count
looks really high,
but keep in mind that's
only 350,000 per eye.
And any time you do hard
normals, which we really
wanted for the aesthetic, it
multiplies the vertex count
by about six.
So In a modeling program
if you look at Design Lab,
it looks like about 60,000
vertices, and you're like wow,
this is great.
This is super low poly.
You pull it into Unity
and you're rendering
700,000 all of a sudden.
That might come as a shock.
"Arctic Journey--" because we
wanted to pull it back even
further, we wanted to
hit the S3 and the S4,
and we really needed
those to get it 60.
VR experiences of 30 just
aren't that compelling.
We brought it down
to 250,000 vertices.
We did that in a number of ways.
A lot of it was just really
old school optimization
techniques--
removing back faces,
reducing model complexity based
on distance from the camera,
and a really custom sort
of stupid LOD system
that, as you change scenes,
we just turned things off.
And we just did it by
hand, nothing really smart.
But that alone wasn't enough.
The rest of the performance
gains for the S3
were made by removing
almost all of the textures
and moving all of the shader
logic out of the pixel shader
and into the vertex shader.
And so that's sort of
the end of part one.
And this is going to seem like
kind of a sudden transition,
but this is important.
Just doing vertex displacement
will get you in the ballpark.
You've got a canvas to
work on, but you still
have to try to find ways to
optimize for these devices.
And that's challenging.
And we really want
to make things
look great without compromising
all those performance gains we
just worked so hard to get.
So now that maybe
you're thinking
about vertex shaders
in a new way,
I'm going to highlight a few
fun things we did with vertex
shaders for other
effects, and then
move on to a really quick review
of our custom lighting model
we created, and wrap up with
a few optimizations tips.
So the first example, the
balloons from Design Lab.
So this is a relatively
simple shader.
We're writing one constant from
the CPU, and that's explosion.
It's written every frame.
And then based on that constant
we scale all the vertices down
and move them out
based on the normal.
And you can see once at
the end, once we finished,
we call that undistort vertex
function from the Cardboard SDK
again, and it applies
the vertex displacement.
And it looks great in VR.
So again, a single floating
point value each frame,
and we can generate
this whole effect.
And this is actually
the case where
we're doing both our
own custom effect
and the vertex displacement,
and we have cast shadows.
So there's a second
depth shader as well
that writes out just
the modified depth, none
of the color information.
In "Arctic Journey," we
have this ocean shader,
which I'm super proud of.
The position values were
generating the vertex shader
sort of in a standard way, three
overlapping sine functions,
just multioctave noise.
The tricky part's recalculating
normals in the vertex shader.
Since vertices don't know
about their neighbors,
you can't just recalculate
normals, right?
So if you're in DX
11, maybe you're
thinking like oh, I'll just
do this on a geometry shader.
But we're on mobile.
Those aren't available
everywhere, until now.
And anyway, they can
still be expensive.
So instead, we packed the
whole triangle into each vertex
by passing the additional verts
through the normal and tangent.
So you can see in that
vertex input struct,
there's position,
normal, and tangent.
But instead of using
the normal and tangent
for normal and tangent, we're
just encoding the other two
vertices.
So we have all three
vertices, and then we can just
do a really quick calculation.
Because we're hard normals,
this is really easy.
If you're doing soft
normals, it would obviously
be a little more complicated.
And then this is an
extension of the same idea.
We needed to get that
draw call count down,
but we really wanted
to have icebergs
that were affected by the
waves and other objects that
were affected by the waves.
So already we've got, what,
10 icebergs in this one area,
and there are
hundreds in the scene.
That's obviously
not going to work.
Draw calls are super expensive.
So to reduce them, we need to
batch them together somehow,
but now we need these
objects to move independently
of each other.
You could do this by rigging
up bones in Maya then animating
the bones, but that's
not going to respond
to your procedural effects.
It's involved.
It's just not fun.
So instead, for each vertex,
we encoded the world space
x and z object location
into the UV channels.
We're not using our UVs anyway.
And then we used that object
location, per iceberg,
to determine the
object y offset.
And then the vertices
just operated normally.
So really simple trick.
We did really like
stupid batching,
but it saved hundreds
of draw calls
and allowed us to get
this effect very cheaply.
OK, so those are some
really basic tricks
we did with the vertex shader.
But now let's talk
about lighting.
Because the major
way we maintain
performance on
both experiences is
by moving the lighting from
the pixel shader to the vertex
shader.
Because we already needed
all that extra tessellation
for the distortion
correction, it
allowed for high quality vertex
lighting at the same time.
And I'm going to show
some of that off.
Many of you when you
hear vertex lighting you
think, oh man, boy, it's
like Nintendo 64 days.
But when you have
enough vertices
and you have so much available
performance in the vert shader,
you can really do a lot.
So it's an entirely
custom lighting model.
I think in both of these
we use a single D-light,
a single directional
light, fog, ambience.
There was optionally
one point light.
We could've added more.
We just didn't need them.
In Design Lab, we wrote a
custom exponential shadow map
solution, specifically
so that we only
had to do the shadows once.
I think Unity now has a
solution for VR shadows.
At the time they didn't,
so we just did it.
Design Lab used textures for
ambient occlusion and color.
"Arctic Journey" used
almost no textures
whatsoever except in very
few really small cases.
I'll go through each of the
major stages, the most common
shader to render this scene.
First of all this, always comes
up, but it happens so often.
It's always worth noting
that the geometry is
rendered before the sky box.
Fill rate is your most expensive
enemy on mobile, doubly so
on VR, whether you're rendering
to vertex displacement
or even more if you're
rendering to the render texture.
But by rendering
the geometry first,
the graphics card
doesn't need to worry
about all those black
pixels that have
been included in the sky box.
The next pass was fog color.
This was interpreted based
on height and distance
to the camera.
This was all configurable.
It was animated so we could
do time of day transitions.
Fog alpha was
calculated separately.
Same sort of deal there.
The ambient term was specified
by two colors, a sky color
from directly
above, and a ground
color from directly below.
The shader interpolated
between these two
based on the object's
surface normal.
Standard Lambertian
version diffuse, N dot L.
And this clearly suffers a
bit from vertex lighting.
Because we used a
hard normal look,
we sort of got away with it.
Oh, and these two foxes-- so
I included these two foxes
because, OK, both "Arctic
Journey" and Cardboard Design
Lab used hard normals for
part of the aesthetic.
But most games
probably don't do that.
If you're making an
application, maybe you
want soft normals, a
really smooth look.
So I included a
soft normal version
of the fox for all
of these images
just so you can get a sense
of what it looks like.
And you can see that
version in this image
really kind of looks bad.
It does look sort of like three
generation old console game.
So depending on the
project, you may
want to do this one calculation
in the pixel shader,
or just keep bumping
the tessellation
until things start to look good.
Vertices are really cheap.
We also added Fresnel.
We're just going
crazy now because we
can do all kinds of math
in here and it's not really
affecting performance.
I'm surprised at how
good this looked.
And then here's all
the lighting combined.
Lastly, we baked
all of the color
into the vertices themselves.
We wrote a little tool
in Unity to read out
the values from a texture
so our artists could
do a normal texture
painting workflow,
and then we just baked
them into the vertices.
That was the way we got rid
of most of the textures.
And then finally the composite.
So I've talked about lighting.
I've talked about
vertex displacement.
And then I'm going to
sort of wrap this up
with some optimization
tips, and then we'll
have a good amount of
time for questions.
So the biggest lesson we learned
really was write your shaders.
When we started up
a Cardboard project
and then tried to build
to really old or low power
devices, we were immediately
running into problems.
This was increased by the
default sky box, the Unity
standard shader.
These things are built for
achieving really great effects
on high power devices,
but you're probably
going to need to scale
things back immediately.
And one of the ways
you can do that
is moving your code
from the pixel shader
to the vert shader, even if
you need to add vertices.
These screens have something
like 4 million pixels.
So any time you're
moving to running
an operation a couple thousand
times, over 4 million times
plus overdraw, you're winning.
The second note, use half
precision, but be careful.
2 to the 16th isn't that big.
One of the examples
we had here, if you're
used to writing shaders
and you write half,
half precision
doesn't exist on PC.
Everything gets compiled to
float, and will run at float.
So you've switched everything
to half precision, great.
And then you make a build
and everything is broken.
In the case we had here,
we had rendered the sun.
The sun was a
pixel shader effect
based on the dot product
of vector direction,
and then a scalar value
for how big it was.
And at some point
someone decided
they wanted to make
the sky box bigger
so that we could see a
further draw distance.
After we did that, I
started getting bug reports
from people testing on
devices that the sun was huge.
And I'm trying to
figure this out,
the sun's huge,
classic engineer thing.
I said no it's not, it's fine.
Nothing's wrong.
And I got a device
and in fact the sun
was taking up the entire sky.
And what had
happened was someone
had scaled the sky box from
200 meters to 300 meters.
And I'm sitting there
scratching my head.
And I looked in there
and they were all halves.
So 256 squared, we were
doing a length calculation,
that number was exploding.
And the sun blew up.
Lastly, get clever with your
vertex data and uniforms.
You can pack a lot of data into
your vertices from the CPU,
and you can do that once.
Things like batching or
packing other vertices in
and calculating your normals.
Moving data, any
time you can move it
from either per vertex
operations on the CPU
to the GPU, or per pixel
operations back to the vertex
shader, you're running.
Textures-- watch out for large,
uncompressed, or non mipmap
textures.
One of the biggest problems
we had on Design Lab
was there was a really small,
uncompressed texture that
didn't have mipmaps
hiding out on one object.
And any time you looked
in one direction,
the performance would drop,
and we couldn't figure it out.
The vertex count
wasn't going up.
The memory wasn't
really increasing.
Finally we found this texture
and flipped the mipmaps on,
and everything was fine.
And what's happening
is, especially
on some of the older devices,
the cache isn't very large,
and you're blowing through
your texture cache.
So those things can
really seem insurmountable
and really confusing.
But if you know what to look
out for, it's not too bad.
Again, on "Arctic Journey,"
we approached this
by removing all of the textures.
It's obviously an easy solution.
Avoid hidden dependent
texture reads.
Nathan Martz actually
mentioned this
to me, something I'd forgotten.
Any time you are
calculating your UV
coordinates in the pixel shader,
it's a dependent texture read
and it goes through a slow path.
And what he reminded me of was
that even swizzle operators
count as dependent
texture reads.
So if you've passed four UV
coordinates from your vertex
shader into your pixel
shader and you're like great,
I can read in the two textures,
this one dot xy, this one dot
zw, those are dependent
texture read on Open GL ES.
And then pack your channels.
Don't just upload an alpha
channel, upload a full RGBA
and use all of your channels.
Or maybe you can bake the
whole texture into vertices
like we did.
OK, optimization.
A lot of people ask us,
how did you optimize?
What's the most important?
And the answer I
always give, first
you really need to profile.
And this can be challenging.
It's often very
hard to figure out
what your limiting factor is.
So we had a lot of really
simple test scenes.
For fill rate, we
usually replace
all of the shaders with
a solid color shader.
That was the easiest way to
tell if we were burning fill.
Make sure things like
the Unity sky box
are turned off if you're
doing these tests.
Other examples, just
removing all the objects
and rendering a cube.
That was actually
how we discovered
that the render texture was
the problem to begin with.
The first test we did on
the S3 that really showed us
we had a problem was just
a simple cube in a room.
Second, it's
probably draw calls.
Eliminating draw calls,
either by batching objects
together or removing
them, is always good.
Third, minimizing
textures, either
by reducing them in size,
removing them all together,
enabling mipmaps,
turning on compression.
Fourth, simply your
fragment shaders if you can.
Pull data into vertex shooters.
And lastly, reducing
your vertex count.
I say lastly because
most of the optimizations
we've been doing
before have been
increasing vertex complexity.
And you may have needed
to increase vertex count.
And typically those
are more important.
Obviously if you're running
10 million vertices,
that balance shifts
a little bit.
Sorry.
Oh right, some resources.
The Cardboard SDK for
Unity of course, which
is a great place to start.
And as I mentioned
at the beginning,
Cardboard Design
Lab is open source.
So definitely go grab that.
You can check out a lot
of this stuff there.
And then one final link, the
Open GL ES optimization tips.
It goes into a lot
more detail of some
of the things I've
mentioned here,
especially some of the weirdness
with swizzling textures,
other things you might run into.
So thank you.
And then, questions?
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: What about chromatic
aberration correction
using these techniques?
BRIAN KEHRER: That's
a great question.
No, we did not do any.
Fortunately the
lenses on Cardboard
don't seem to exhibit a whole
lot of chromatic aberration.
But yeah, if you're on a
headset that does, you're shot.
That's a great case for
using a render texture.
AUDIENCE: And the
second question,
how does this technique
relate to Daydream?
BRIAN KEHRER: Right, so this
is not supported on Daydream
because Daydream
is using a render
texture for a few effects,
some electronic stabilization
and a few others.
I just found out
about Daydream today.
So those guys are on the--
what's the channel, sorry?
AUDIENCE: The space.
BRIAN KEHRER: The
space, right, the space.
So if you ask them, they
can give you more detail.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Implementation
about the distortion,
is it in the source so we
can check a little bit how
it was done?
BRIAN KEHRER: Yeah, so the cginc
that Cardboard is included,
it's just using a Brown-Conrady
expansion of terms.
So it's squared, fourth.
But it's all in there
so you can see it.
I didn't include
it just because it
started to get a little
bit math heavy and then
like a lot of code.
But it's all in there.
So check it out.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
AUDIENCE: I think that
was my second question.
The source code's available
through the GitHib
repo that you--
BRIAN KEHRER: Yeah, do you want
me to-- I can click it back.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so Unity
[INAUDIBLE], Unity [INAUDIBLE]?
BRIAN KEHRER: Yeah, if you check
out the Cardboard Design Lab
source, it's in there.
AUDIENCE: And the
second question,
do you do a brute force render
for the left and right eye,
or do you optimize by
material in your shader?
BRIAN KEHRER: Yeah,
so one of the things
I was thinking
about doing was what
if we packed all
the data into-- what
if we packed the left and right
vertices into a single object,
and then passed in two matrices?
We didn't get
there because there
were some other problems
with clipping and coloring
and stuff.
I just didn't have time, really.
But yes, I think
that's possible.
Anyone else?
Anyone?
Cool.
[MUSIC PLAYING]